the greatest people are self-managing
they don't need to be managed you if
they know what if once they know what to
do they'll go figure out how to do it
they don't need to be managed at all
what they need is a common vision and
that's what leadership is what
leadership is is having a vision being
able to articulate that so that people
around you can understand it and getting
a consensus on a common vision we wanted
people that were insanely great at what
they did but were not necessarily those
seasoned professionals but who has on at
the tips of their fingers and in their
passion the latest understanding of
where technology was and what we could
do with that technology and who wanted
to bring that to lots of people so the
neatest thing that happens is when you
get a core group of you know 10 great
people that it becomes self-policing as
to who they let into that group so I
consider the most important job of
someone like myself is recruiting
agonized over hiring we had interviews I
go back and look at some of the
interviews again they would start at
9:00 or 10:00 in the morning and go
through dinner a new interviewee would
talk to everybody in the building at
least once maybe a couple times and then
come back for another round of
interviews and then we'd all get
together and talk about it and then
before that no no no it's critical part
of the interview at least to my mind was
when we finally decided we liked them
enough to show them the Macintosh
prototype and then snap them down in
front of it and if they just kind of
were bored or said this is a nice
computer we don't want it we wanted
their eyes to light up and then to get
really excited and then we knew they
were one of us and everybody just wanted
to work not because it was work that had
to be done but it was because something
that we really believed in that was just
going to really make a difference and
that's what kept the whole thing going
we all wanted exactly the same thing
instead of spending our time arguing
about what the computer should be we all
knew what the computer should be and we
just went in debt we went through that
stage and Apple where we went out and we
thought oh we're going to be a big
company let's hire professional
management we went out and hired a bunch
of professional management it didn't
work at all most of them were bozos they
knew how to manage but they didn't know
how to do anything
and so what if you're a great person why
do you want to work for something you
can't learn anything from and you know
what's interesting you know who the best
managers are there are the great
individual contributors who never ever
want to be a manager but the side they
have to be a manager because every no
one else is going to be able to do as
good a job as them after hiring two
professional managers from outside the
company and firing them both jobs
gambled on Debbie Coleman a member of
the Macintosh team 32 years old an
English literature major with an MBA
from Stanford
Debbie was a financial manager with no
experience in manufacturing I mean
there's no way in the world anybody else
but give me this chance to run this kind
of operation and I don't kid myself
about that this is an incredible high
risk both for myself personally and
professionally and for Apple as the
company that put a person like myself in
this job I mean they're really betting
on a lot of things we're betting that my
skills at organizational effectiveness
you know override all of you know lack
of technology lack of experience lack of
you know time and manufacturing so it's
a big risk and I'm just an example in
every single person on the Mac team
almost to your you know entry level
person you can say that about this is a
place where people were afforded
incredibly unique opportunities to prove
that they could do it fit them they
could write the book again inscribed
inside the casing of every Macintosh
unseen by the consumer are the
signatures of the whole team this is
Apple's way of affirming that their
latest innovation is a product of the
individuals who created it not the
corporation